In the United States, the government says it will send up to 50 special forces to Syria...
...in an advisory role in the fight against Islamic State militants.
In Austria, major world powers call for a truce in Syria's four-year civil war,...
...a renewal of the stalled UN-brokered peace talks...
...between the government and the opposition.
In Greece, at least 22 migrants, many of them children, drown when two boats sink...
...in the Aegean Sea while traveling from Turkey to Greece.
In South Korea, the commander of the USS Ronald Reagan says...
...the US will continue to navigate in international waters,...
...including the South China Sea.
And finally, in Israel, police say a Palestinian was shot and seriously wounded...
...after carrying out a knife attack in Jerusalem.